more than a million people are expected
to attend events in Atlanta in the ten
days leading up to next week's Superbowl
many hoping to paint the town red but
Atlanta has been doing some painting of
its own the project is called off the
wall Atlanta's civil rights and social
justice journey told through a series of
murals organizers say it's about
honoring the past acknowledging the
present and setting aspirations for the
future Atlanta native Shaniqua gay says
she was the kid who always drew on her
parents walls today she's putting the
finishing touches on an entire
building's wall in her hometown I think
the connection of arts and civil rights
right they married together beautifully
gays mural remembering sweet Auburn is
no mosh to the neighborhood once
considered the country's most prosperous
african-american community in the early
20th century it's one of them more than
two dozen murals around the city
expected to be completed by next week to
greet the more than 100,000 visitors
here for Superbowl 53 what do you hope
they take away from it how amazing
Atlanta is the contribution that is
given to this nation and how can they
contribute moving forward gays panorama
is steps from many of Atlanta's storied
Civil Rights landmarks the Martin Luther
King jr. National Historic Site which
includes his boyhood home and the
Ebenezer Baptist Church where he
preached roads bearing the names of
pioneering politicians like Andrew Young
Jr a US congressman UN Ambassador and
Atlanta mayor when you see your mural
there do you ever get used to it I never
get used to it
Congressman John Lewis has represented
Atlanta in the US House of
Representatives since 1987 24 years
after he organized and addressed the
march on Washington 22 years after he
was beaten for leading protesters across
the Edmund Pettus Bridge in Selma
Alabama Lewis received the Presidential
Medal of Freedom in 2011 the following
year he was honored with his mural and
says he's excited to have some company a
piece of art such as a mirror
can not only tell the story but it can
inspire others to learn to find a way to
make a contribution toward creating a
better Atlanta a better Georgia and a
better world I love that it is a girl
flexing and that that's not what you
would necessarily expect artists are
great great storytellers in that way
it's that he'd surprise us Chris
Appleton is the executive director of
wonder route the organization that
launched the mural project the public
works of art appeared throughout Atlanta
from commuter train stations to
storefronts they depict civil rights and
social justice themes past and present
created with community input by eleven
artists from across the country
including an undocumented dreamer living
in Atlanta and Baltimore muralist Ernest
Shaw who's Atlanta's strong just outside
mercedes-benz stadium will greet fans
coming to the game on Super Bowl Sunday
I feel like some people might say look
it's the Super Bowl why are we looking
at something that has to do with social
justice I think two things it's
certainly the Super Bowl in the NFL have
an important role to play in addressing
social justice issues in our country I
think we've seen that conversation
continue to play out but also when these
kinds of big events right they can be
galvanizing moments and you also have
eyeballs now that you would never have
otherwise we do and it takes eyeballs to
make change a lot of my work focuses on
hidden figures if you will the stories
of women and their work in resistance
and activism and service muralist
Charmaine Minnie fields visionary for
justice on Atlanta's West Side pays
tribute to Ruby Doris Smith Robinson
she was a young activist during the
civil rights movement she was the
backbone of the snick movement which is
the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee art is supposed to spark
conversation is that what these murals
are doing oh my goodness well I you know
I've said the term art is the heartbeat
of humanity before because it's the
place where we all are equal and if we
can give each other the chance to fully
openly freely express that express those
stories and those narratives but I feel
like that's where the real change and
understanding can really take place now
all of the murals will be conserved and
maintained by the city of Atlanta as
part of its permanent public art
collection a legacy gift to the city
Chris Appleton says from he's from
wonder root and the Super Bowl and it's
really amazing to see these images going
up because you know the NFL may not want
to have the social justice conversation
at the Super Bowl but it needs to be had
there because there are so many people
and that's what people are trying to
place I love the philosophy that art is
the heartbeat of humanity sure is and
what who knew about Doris Smith Robinson
we know of the John Lewis's that's
exactly Andy Young yeah and that I was
going to say that's what some of these
artists said they wanted to give voice
to people you didn't know into all
different communities in social justice
LGBTQ the dreamers yeah obviously the
civil rights movement I love that story